para el gobierno francés el verano ha
terminado es hora de volver al trabajo
en un aleccionador discurso a su
gabinete en el primer día de regreso el
presidente manuel ma con anunció el fin
de una era despreocupada de abundancia y
advirtió que se avecinan meses difíciles
nuestra libertad la libertad a la que
nos hemos acostumbrado en nuestras vidas
tiene un precio y a veces cuando hay que
defenderla hay que hacer ciertos
sacrificios
francia se enfrenta a un invierno de
posible escasez energética en medio de
la amenaza de que rusia corte las
exportaciones de gas a europa
consecuencia de la guerra de ucrania
otra prioridad en la agenda el medio
ambiente aunque esperábamos que este
verano fuera más tranquilo que los dos
últimos marcados por la pandemia de kobe
19 hay una serie de cuestiones que ha
empezado en la moral de los franceses en
su vida cotidiana me refiero por
supuesto al aumento del costo de vida a
las sequías históricas que hemos vivido
a las olas de calor a los incendios
forestales y a las tormentas después de
una de las temporadas más calurosas
desde 1900 y de mortíferos eventos
climáticos
es cada vez más difícil de ignorar el
ministerio de medioambiente francés está
trabajando en un amplio paquete para
tratar de diversificar la combinación
energética del país apostando por las
renovables en estrecha relación el costo
de vida la inflación y el desempleo con
una próxima reforma de las prestaciones
son temas candentes junto con la reforma
de las pensiones por la que ya se espera
una huelga multisectorial el 29 de
septiembre pero mayor no sólo se
enfrenta al reto de las protestas sino
también a las difíciles negociaciones
para aprobar su presupuesto en la
asamblea nacional sin mayoría absoluta y
con una oposición bastante bulliciosa el
gobierno de macon podría tener que sacar
adelante sus proyectos de ley su
presupuesto por la fuerza un escenario
que irritaría el parlamento que vuelve
al trabajo el 3 de octubre
[Aplausos]